[Music]
an eight news now community pride
partner
intermountain healthcare the sponsors of
this next segment are here for our
seniors with convenient facilities and
locations around town we stop by to
learn more
[Music]
this one is for our seniors it's a
special clinic just for you welcome to
intermountain nevada i am dr ann gerani
suarez one of the medical directors here
with this wonderful organization here at
the mygen senior focus clinics we pride
ourselves on what we're able to provide
for our patients easy access more time
with your provider lab facility here on
a site having a care coordinating team
to really help make this your medical
home and there's over 30 conveniently
located mygen senior clinics throughout
southern nevada so you and your
neighbors are well taken care of
in the mygen senior focus clinics
providers have smaller panel sizes
therefore they're able to spend the time
that they need with their patients
bringing them back as often as they need
our goal is comprehensive care for our
senior patients from the time they come
into the clinic you'll see that there's
wider seats there's wider doors our exam
tables are lower to be really focused on
our senior patients
in addition to comprehensive services we
pride ourselves in the preventative
services we're able to offer our
patients in fact we meet on a regular
basis to talk about our patients and
really coordinate a team around them to
help them leave their healthiest lives
possible with the comprehensive and
preventative services we provide our my
generation senior patients they have 40
percent less hospitalization
especially considering the times that we
are now it's absolutely imperative that
we're helping to take care of our
patients outside of the hospital setting
and this is truly a medical home where
they can turn to and feel secure and
safe at each clinic location we have a
care team in place to help each patient
in their medicare advantage plan
coordinate and integrate care with our
specialists in order to help patients
live the healthiest lives possible
so come and join us we would love to
take care of you we make it really easy
to access our services please call or
visit us online you'll see all the
various places that we're located so we
can be your medical home
for more information all you gotta do is
head to intermountainhealthcare.org
nevada or simply just walk right into
the location nearest you to talk to your
care team
thank you intermountain healthcare for
sponsoring this segment you can visit
them online the address is right there
on your screen we'll be